يقول رئيس أركان الرئيس ترامب
إن الرئيس يظهر
أعراضًا خفيفة من فيروس كورونا إذا
أصيب الرئيس ترامب بمرض شديد ، قال
أحد المحللين إنه من المحتمل أن يكون هناك
قلق كبير داخل الجناح الغربي
إذا لم يكن هناك بالفعل موظفو البيت الأبيض
والموظفون السياسيون بشأن ترامب
يجب أن يكون
متوترًا للغاية ، فهذا يدمر الكثير
من الخطط التي كانت لديهم ،
لقد حصلت على البعد الصحي ،
إذا كان الرئيس ترامب مريضًا جدًا بحيث لا يمكنه
التحكم في ما سيحدث بعد ذلك ،
فإن الخطوة الأولى هي تحديد أنه عاجز
وفقًا لـ  التعديل الخامس والعشرون
للدستور الرابح يمكن أن
يقرر
بنفسه أنه يمكنه إخطار الكونجرس
ومجلس الشيوخ بأنه سيكون
عاجزًا لأنه سيتم تخديره
على جهاز التنفس الصناعي وحتى يقول
ذلك سيتم نقل صلاحيات مكتبه
إلى
مايك بنس الذي كان يعمل كرئيس بالنيابة
حتى تتحسن صحة الرئيس
رونالد ريغان فعل ذلك عندما أجرى عملية جراحية
على مرحبًا  قام
جورج دبليو بوش بذلك مرتين عندما أجرى
تنظير القولون
، سلما كل منهما السلطة
لبضع ساعات فقط بينما كانا تحت
التخدير ،
ولكن ماذا لو كان الرئيس مريضًا جدًا وغير
متماسك لدرجة أنه لا يستطيع أن
يقرر بنفسه تسليم السلطة
يحتوي التعديل الخامس والعشرون على خطة لذلك
أيضًا ، يمكن لنائب الرئيس وأغلبية
أعضاء مجلس الوزراء إخطار الكونغرس كل
من مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ
بأن الرئيس عاجز ،
وعند هذه
النقطة تنتقل الصلاحيات من الرئيس ترامب
إلى نائب الرئيس
إذا كان بنس و  مجلس الوزراء لا يتفق
مع بعضهم البعض على أخذ السلطة من
الرئيس ترامب
، وسيتعين على الغالبية العظمى من أعضاء
الكونجرس التصويت على الاستيلاء على السلطة من
بنس ترامب حتى الآن جاءت نتيجة اختبار
فيروس كورونا سلبية ، ويقول طبيبه إنه
يتمتع بصحة جيدة
لكن كوفيت تسلل إلى البيض
كان البيت والرئيس ترامب على
اتصال وثيق مع
بنس إذا أصيب بنس بالفيروس وأصبح
عاجزًا
بعد ذلك ليكون الرئيس بالنيابة
سيكون
نانسي بيلوسي ، رئيسة مجلس النواب الديمقراطي المنافس لدور الرئيس ترامب ،
لا أعتقد أنهم سيسمحون بحدوث ذلك لأنهم
سيجدون طريقة للتغلب عليه ،
ربما يكون وزير الخارجية شخصًا
في الخط الجمهوري
إما الخط الانتخابي في مجلس الشيوخ
أو
الخط الوزاري  تولي
الأمر لا يمكن الدفاع عنه ، وستدرك نانسي بيلوسي
أنه أيضًا
إذا تم تجاوز بيلوسي أو لا
تريد الوظيفة ، فإن القواعد تتطلب
أن تذهب الرئاسة إلى رئيس مجلس
الشيوخ المؤقت
الذي يبلغ من العمر 87 عامًا في الوقت الحالي
الجمهوري تشاك غراسلي.
يخاف الأمريكيون من كل هذه
الاحتمالات ، يجب
ألا يخاف الجمهور مطلقًا في حين أن هذا
الموقف
صعب ، فلدينا
أحكام دستورية وقانونية
للتعامل مع هذا
الموقف والمواقف أكثر خطورة
وأكثر تعقيدًا بكثير من الوضع
الحالي ولكن مفتاح آخر  السؤال هو
ماذا عن الانتخابات ماذا لو
أصبح أحد المرشحين أو كلاهما
عاجزًا أو
مات من الفيروس ولا شيء من هذا القبيل
حدث من قبل من قبل
حتى الآن ، أثبت اختبار جو بايدن أنه سلبي لفيروس
كورونا
لكن الخبراء يقولون إنه إذا كان على أي من
المرشحين الانسحاب لأي سبب من الأسباب ،
فسيتعين على اللجان الوطنية الجمهورية أو الديمقراطية
أن
تتدافع
لاختيار مرشح جديد اقتراحًا مشبوهًا
في وقت متأخر.  اللعبة
لأن الكثير من الناس صوتوا بالفعل
لبريان تود سي إن إن
واشنطن